hundred megawatts of gas powered
generate generation
is still offline because of either
mechanical issues or the lack of
the supply of gas for those gas
generators to produce
power 17 200 megawatts of renewable
generated power remain out either
because of freezing
of the wind or because of lack of sun
for the solar
some natural gas produced in texas
and this is this is i'm about to tell
you a way in which we will be adding
more
power to our system some natural gas
produced in texas
is currently being shipped to locations
outside of the state
i have earlier today
issued an order effective today through
february the 21st
requiring those producers that have been
shipping
to locations outside of texas to instead
sell that natural gas to texas
power generators that will also
increase the power that's going to be
produced and sent to homes
here in texas that will increase the
ability of
gas power generators in texas to
increase power sent
to the texas power grid
through multiple phone calls and actions
the white house has assisted texas with
orders that
allow additional power generation
or have accelerated the nuclear plant
restoration
also another issue that i will be coming
to here shortly
is talking
the public utilities commission those
include for the most part
encore centerpoint energy aep
and texas new mexico power
and an order has been made to ensure
that everybody that is subject to
regulation by the puc
will have access to power at
on at least a rotating basis during the
remaining time period
until power is fully up and running
i have some more information to cover
but i want to let you know
a couple of topics that will be coming
up
that will be addressed by other people
at the table
a broad category is the emergency
response efforts to help texans in need
at this time and that will be addressed
by chief nem kid of the texas division
of emergency management
another is in many regions across texas
there are increasing challenges with
regard to water quality
they will be addressed by toby becker
the executive director for the texas
commission
on environmental quality
i want to address an issue that some
texans are already beginning to deal
with but many texans will be
having to deal with here in the coming
days that i want to make sure that we
start discussing
right now and that is the results
of busted pipes many people have already
experienced busted pipes and they've had
their homes or their apartments or other
locations already filled up with water
so let's talk about what can be done and
where we're going with it one thing that
you want to do
if you have a busted pipe or to prevent
the consequences of a busted pipe
is consider turning off your water
supply
if you are a homeowner there should be a
location typically outside maybe
near the curbside where you have a the
ability to
physically turn off the water supply to
your house
obviously that will eliminate water
supply to your house
you can turn turn it off at the time of
your choosing
if you do not turn it off one thing that
could happen is that when power does
come back onto your house or when
uh just because the outside temperature
begins to warm up
there will come a point in time when the
ice frozen in your pipes will begin to
melt and
the busted pipe will suddenly start
spewing water
throughout your house maybe in multiple
locations
one way to slow down that water flooding
into your house is by
taking that action in advance to turn
off your water
we also urge all homeowners to
as quickly as possible like as in
beginning now if you haven't already
done so
begin to work with a plumber
get plumbers lined up and work with your
insurance company
in advance if you're a homeowner you
should
have homeowners insurance that would
address this talk to your agent
today tonight tomorrow immediately
if you are a renter most renters are
required to have renter's insurance
talk to your rental insurance as well as
your landlord
immediately about what to do and how to
address this
if you live in a location that is not
covered by
insurance you may have the possibility
of getting assistance from fema as you
know i requested a
federal disaster declaration and that
was granted one thing that comes along
that is
fema assistance part of that fema
assistance goes to what's called public
assistance that
works on the rebuilding of large
municipal and governmental based
facilities
another component would be individual
assistance
in order to qualify for individual
assistance
there are certain dollar metrics that
must be met
before a location qualifies so what we
need homeowners to do
is if you are without insurance
if you live in a region where you may be
covered by fema
we need everyone to
keep receipts of any cost that you have
occurred
as a result of any type of repair to
your property that's needed
as a consequence of this winter storm
along these lines also texas law
already authorizes the plumbing board
to give provisional licenses to
out-of-state plumbers
and we're urging that that take place
and also working with the board of
plumbing examiners
to make sure that that will happen
with regard to that authorization
we are also working to
in fact i am going to be issuing a
waiver
for plumbers if they are previously
licensed as a plumber
but haven't completed continuing
education
in the last two years you will be
allowed to provide for
plumbers a license to assist
with those who have been affected by the
winter storm
the goal obviously is we're trying to
make sure
that we will have as many plumbers
available as possible to help
everybody deal with their plumbing
challenges
similarly and relatedly texas law also
provides
insurance adjusters out of state can get
a temporary license
to do it adjusting for disaster claims
that's important because we do expect a
lot of people
in texas to have disaster claims whether
it be
with your home because of damages that
could occur to your home or to your
rental property or
because of a car accident etc and so we
are urging
the insurance businesses in texas
to bring in as many insurance adjusters
from
across the state as possible
also i'll mention something that chief
nem kid with
the texas division of emergency
management will expand upon shortly
but that the division of emergency
management is already working with
voads as well as faith-based
organizations
to help homeowners repair their homes
many of you will recall this process for
people who
were affected by hurricane harvey
and we brought those same organizations
in to
help people muck out their homes and
repair their homes and
the texas division of emergency
management was involved in
lining up all those people to assist in
that repair process
we're already beginning to line up those
people and so
you may be wondering well how can you
get a hold of somebody who can
be connected with a voad or a faith
based organization who can assist you
and the answer is you can call your
local office
of emergency management organizations
either
with the county or city that you live in
it just depends on
where you happen to reside
one other thing on my part then i'll
turn it off turn over to
to nem kid and and chief kid will also
touch upon this a little bit so
uh the the the the primary component of
the texas military division is the
national guard and we're very thankful
to the national guard and the role they
applied and continue to play
in assisting the state in our people
in responding to this winter storm
the national guard is assisting with
regard to warming centers across the
state
that chief kid will talk more about they
are also assisting with regard to
roadways and providing air crews
for a variety of different efforts to
make sure that we are better able as a
state to address this challenge
but in details about that as well as so
many other issues
will be provided to you by the next
speaker chief
nem kid the chief of the texas division
of emergency management
thank you governor and the list that i
will go through
is very detailed but it is not
exhaustive this does not cover any of
the great work being done by
our local partners and some of the state
agencies i will not cover here today
uh but governor i think i need to take a
second first
to thank the men and women in this room
that have been working around the clock
their families that are at home going
through the same experiences that most
texans are going through right now
and so i want to thank them very quickly
start with the texas department of
transportation all 25 districts across
texas are still impacted
they have over 4 500 textile employees
out on the roads right now operating
over 740 snow plows
another 225 motor graders all working to
de-ice the interstate system and keep
the network up and running
there are over 5200 road sections that
are still
affected by this with 37 closures
they're working very closely with the
forest service
county commissioners construction
contractors and renting every piece of
equipment they can find to help keep
roads open
i think one of the most important jobs
that they have right now
is prioritizing and clearing routes to
critical infrastructure
and coordinating with local governments
for access to hospitals
working with the public utility
commission to make sure that the power
plants are still up and running and
access to them
and working with our fuel vendor
transition to the men and women of the
texas department of public safety
over 3 300 troopers on the road around
the clock
responding to over 1600 crashes that
they investigate again that does not
count our local government law
enforcement agencies and county sheriffs
that are out there working
dps supporting them supporting the
division of emergency management
parks and wildlife i'll tell you they've
uh in addition to roadside assistance
investigating crashes and supporting
other local law enforcements
department of public safety troopers
have delivered blood to hospitals
they've delivered fuel to power plants
they've relocated residents from nursing
homes
and provided additional fuel to first
responders
you heard a little bit about the texas
military department and their personnel
that are working
not only to assist people that are
stranded on the roads
but personnel available to assist in
supporting the warming centers and i'll
go over that list here in just a minute
working with an air operation center as
soon as it is safe to start flying we'll
be flying resources all across this
state
and working to find all available
generators that may be supporting any
military operation that can be pushed
out into the field to support civilian
operations
texas military department will bring on
additional aircraft c-130s and
helicopters to be able to fly
water cots blankets and whatever we need
into places that are still hampered by
the state's transportation network
texas parks and wildlife game wardens
and state police officers are out on the
streets also supporting dps
over 430 game wardens and 90 park police
officers all in four wheel drive
vehicles they're helping move
people around as well game wardens have
assisted numerous calls from services
ranging from delivery of blankets to
answering calls for local law
enforcement and welfare checks
yesterday the abilene game wardens were
requested to deliver supplies to
reynolds county
for the blackouts they delivered
blankets cots and other warming supplies
in addition game wardens in gonzales
county
worked with seguin electric to hook up
the generator of the children's home
i'm not sure how many game wardens uh
are out there that are
certified licensed electricians but i'm
certainly thankful for working
the work that they do with our local
electric companies to get this done and
deliver these life-saving materials and
supplies
they're going and picking up extension
cords and moving generators and fuel
around everywhere that they can
texas a m forest service also supporting
local agencies including the
department of transportation crews
working in the panhandle all over the
state with motor graders four wheel
drive vehicles you know a lot of the
things that we use to put fire out with
and forest fires are also clearing roads
right now
so pure integration between the state
agencies personnel all over the state
zapata county to galveston county up
into the panhandle nacogdoches
saw crews are available to start
clearing some of the
access to critical infrastructure as
trees have fallen we want to make sure
those trees are out of the way
panhandle branch of the a m4 service
is blading interstates and highways
working together
removing patrol over 1200 miles of tier
two and tier three roads so not the main
interstate system but trying to keep our
county roads open as well
winter weather operations in kimball and
current menard counties along with the
san angelo district
clearing jackknife so the forest service
firefighters are out there clearing
roads as well just like record drivers
the abilene branch as well working with
incident management teams to support the
city of coleman and county for resources
and get additional generators and power
to them
i could go on for about five days on the
other counties that they're working on
but i'll skip through
a lot of engine company out there work
out there to make sure that as soon as
water becomes available we'll set up
points of distribution operations
and will continue to support our local
government partners
i told you about our mass care warming
sites if you remember day one we had
about 30
warming centers then we went up to 100
now we're up to a little over 300
warming centers
they're broken down across all areas of
the state a lot of them are supported by
local government
voads as the governor mentioned we'll
put additional resources in there as we
need to make sure that there's drinking
water
cots blankets if you're looking for a
place where a warming center is and you
have
an internet connection you can go to
tdmtdem.texas.gov
warm or if you have a telephone you can
call two one
one two one one texas has the list of
all 298 resource
warming centers that are out there right
now we will continue to work with our
local government partners to add
additional warming centers as required
the texas a m engineering extension
service continues to port our resource
staging areas all across the state we're
working with at t the telephone company
to help refuel their cell towers and
generators to keep our
cell system up and running during covid
governor we created recreated something
called the pony express
where we were using all of the a m
agencies to move ppe and testing
materials around
pony express is still working for this
event they've transported essential
workers to hospitals and assisting
living centers
and power companies and also supplies to
the warming centers the department of
state health services is working with
our hospitals across the state
there's a lot of water main breaks that
are causing problems for our hospitals
we'll continue to resource as much water
for them as we can as well as oxygen
cylinders we're hearing some oxygen
shortages that are out there so we
continue to work
with our private sector partners as well
as our federal partners to bring in
additional
oxygen we're working with our long-term
care facilities
the diastasis centers dialysis is a is a
very important
network that we need to continue to work
it requires a lot of electricity and a
lot of water
so we're moving through our emergency
medical task force moving people that
need dialysis to places where dialysis
can be delivered
there are multiple regional patient
evacuation missions that have been going
on through the emergency medical task
force program
the emergency medical task force emtf
has deployed ambulance strike teams on
state mission assignments
locations throughout the state and
supporting additional star requests
kimball county in junction our ambush
went out there and it has since been
demobilized but transported patients
back to san antonio
and buses and garland have been
activated coleman county activated
and again a list here from itascasita to
fort bend to hopkins county to frisco to
fort bend county to flower mound to
cedar hill to frisco
all working across the state moving
patients from places that don't have
electricity to places that do
we continue to support our local
government partners with the ambush
program and
and really thank you to all of those
local responders that are helping with
that
the two-day ambus missions have
relocated over 300 personnel
health and human services continues to
work with our regulatory for the six
facilities
that have had frozen broken leak and
pipes 32 have reported power outages
and 10 of those have evacuations that
are in process we continue to support
our local health authorities and local
health administrations and continue to
support 2-1-1
2-1-1 has done a tremendous job in
taking a number of calls
i think the wait time is down to three
to five minutes they brought on the
right people governor to be able to
answer the questions
so big hats off to the health and human
services commission
and while people is our main focus
agriculture is still a way of life in
texas the texas animal health commission
the texas department of agriculture a m
agrilife extension and a m veterinary
emergency medical team have been out
working to support our livestock areas
yesterday they hosted a call with all
the industry leaders to make sure that
gas curtailments can also not have a
beer impact on our livestock so that
we'll continue to get our food in the
future
and then finally uh last word on
recovery
you've heard of other texas voads our
volunteer organizations active in
disaster
great partners to us in every event we
do have a 254 county
emergency declaration we're working with
fema
to increase that for public assistance
and individual assistance
as governor mentioned that's going to
require some proving of damages
we have disaster summary outlines from
our local government partners that are
already sending in their dsos to us
our disaster recovery task force is
working remotely all across the state
with our voads
and it will be important that we work
with your insurance company
first your insurance company if you do
not have insurance then our volunteer
organization is active in disaster our
faith-based organizations will be ready
to help
and we will work very closely with fema
on the recovery process
i i gotta say another quick thank you to
our fema partners who have been here in
the room with us the entire time
they are helping us resource water cots
blankets and generators
we'll also continue to work with our
private sector partners to make sure
that the infrastructure to support them
to support citizens is up and working
with our local food banks as well to
make sure that those are in need of food
have a place to get it
thank you people who see you respond to
hurricanes are accustomed to seeing you
go through that list
on coastal-based counties but this is
different because
all 254 counties have been affected i
just i want to circle back on one thing
you were talking about and that's to
make sure that everybody knows
where and how they can access warming
centers
in the event they need to go to one uh
if i recall correctly
if you live in a city you can call 3-1-1
yes sir
and if you live in a rural area call
2-1-1
if you do have access to the internet
you gave them an address location they
can go to and that is
it's tdem dot texas spelled out
dot gov slash warm w-a-r-m
also i i found it just by going to
google and typing in
warming center in texas and it'll show
locations near you where you can get
access to a warming center
in addition to those issues there are
many issues
that have been addressed by multiple
agencies in the state of texas
one of which is the texas railroad
commission and we have with us
uh commissioner christie craddock thank
you governor
and it has been an unusual time so at
the railroad commission we obviously are
working
on gas issues first and foremost we've
been meeting every day
with the texas energy reliability
council
it's made up of gas electric puc
railroad commission and other uh
did i miss some oil and gas operators
pipelines
trying to make sure that our grid is is
moving and we
get reports from the gas people every
day
i will say we've had multiple calls on
top of that with operators
to make sure that we start getting gas
online so the good news
in the west and in the southern part of
the state
is that we're beginning to unfreeze and
in doing so
we've been working with the puc to try
to make sure
there is electricity out to some of
these well sites and these
processing plants so gas can start
moving in this state
it's really important that being said
we've had a lot of gas in the state
if you are getting gas into your home
you're getting it because our gas
producers
are getting gas to the state they're
doing with maximum withdrawal
we not only produce but we have storage
facilities in the state so they're doing
maximum withdrawal
producing areas getting back online
that's a plus for us long term
look our priorities have been working
with our with both teetum
as well as txdot puc and other state and
local agencies to make sure
our operators can get back onto their
leases and
to make sure that they're safe first and
foremost as well
and to continue to provide that gas to
texas
and this evening we will meet as an
agent to
see to extend our priority order to make
sure that residentials are being
uh provided for with and also human
needs like
uh local distribution companies as well
as power generation
and as a reminder and look i've one of
those that been without power for
a lot of hours too so as have a couple
members of my family and several members
of my staff
but reminder please don't use your gas
where you're not supposed to we are
having carbon monoxide issues
we want you to be safe we want you to be
warm but don't get carbon monoxide
poisoning don't use your gas how you're
not supposed to
so it is a real safety issue as well if
you see an issue
with your gas as well as a broken
pipeline or something like that
that you knew as a no is a gas pipeline
please call your local distribution
company your gas
company that you get your gas from let
them come out
inspect it turn it off safely we want to
make sure people are safe
as we continue to warm up in the next
week
thank you governor thank you an issue
that
is increasingly arising our water
quality issues
as well as environmental issues and the
state is working to address that
primarily under the leadership of the
texas commission on environmental
equality
the executive director of which is toby
baker thank you governor um
we've seen over uh the last 24 hours
the number of local drinking water
systems
um being impacted go up significantly
as of noon today there were 332 local
water systems reporting impacts
in 110 counties across the state
270 issued boil water notices
the current population impacted by boil
water notices is
just under 7 million texans the
population impacted by non-operational
systems at this time is about 263
958. i want to prepare the public
specifically on these local water
systems because when a boil water notice
is issued
to come off of that notice there has to
be bacteriological sampling done
for that system that sampling can take
up to 24 hours so as the roads start to
thaw
your power starts to come back on you
may not see your boil water notice
lift until that sampling is done
there are currently about 135 labs
accredited labs across the state that
can do that sampling
we are reaching out specifically to each
of those labs and we will be assisting
local water systems
in connecting with those labs when
they're ready to get those samples
submitted
we've also partnered with the epa to
start looking at labs in other states
our partnering states around us to try
to access some of those labs as well so
we don't run into a bottleneck
with with the testing the uh part of the
reason for the the
number of impacted systems or the reason
is obviously number one
um lack of power the power's gone down
number two
frozen lines that have led to breaks
in those lines and then finally with
everyone dripping their faucets
extreme use of the water in one system
for example
we saw usage that was near peak
summer demand usage for water because of
people dripping their pipes
and pulling the the pressure down on the
system so we will continue to
connect local water systems with those
labs
but it is a it is an ongoing issue and
this numbers
is probably going to grow over the next
day or two
thank you governor thank you and and
thank all of you we'll take a few
questions
and maybe austin and they just maybe in
san antonio new paper that airline right
now is ready to
use lying to the public so if you can
explain to us which it is
you think it's renewable natural gas
so over the past uh 24 to 48 hours
i have conducted about
uh two dozen or more interviews and i
have repeatedly talked about
how every source of power
that the state of texas has has been
compromised
whether it be renewable power such as
wind or solar but also as i mentioned
today
access to coal generated power access to
gas generated power also have been
compromised
whether it be with regard to systems
freezing up
or equipment failures as well as
our nuclear power facility so the the
fact is
every source of power the state of texas
has
access to has been compromised because
of the
ultra cold temperature or because of
equipment failures
implying that we're part of that and
this is the reason we all get today
because we didn't invest enough in other
languages but in fact
we invested too much in great new deal
are you saying you don't want to invest
any more than green energy
what i made clear was the fact that if
we
relied solely upon green energy that
would be a challenge
but in texas we do not rely solely upon
green energy we have access to all
sources of energy
not at all not at all yeah that's not
what i said
right so
today i spoke with both the lieutenant
governor and speaker
and both the house and senate uh will
begin investigations if i understand
correctly next week
and that will begin a process where we
fully evaluate exactly
uh what was done and maybe what was not
done uh
in both the decision process as well as
the action process
uh by ercot uh making sure uh that we
get to the root of
any missteps that took place what was
done what can be done better
as you point out as i stated on local tv
stations as well as local radio shows
i talked about the challenges to all of
the power generation
sources that we have in the state of
texas including
wind and solar but also including coal
including natural gas and including
nuclear also i was asked a question
on one tv show about
renewable and i responded to that
question
you mentioned a lot of things that are
on the way with water
blankets and cuts can you do a time
table or is it just a matter of
when they're the weather gives you the
opportunity
to that i'm sorry an opportunity to what
so we we're delivering them uh to the
rural counties
we've already delivered them to rural
counties but chief kidd
will have the details about that so
governor you're exactly right a lot of
these deliveries have already been made
as more requests more will come out
there are some places that the roads are
just so bad we can't get to them
that's why we're bringing up the air
operations center to be able to fly
resources
in but this isn't uh we're going to wait
until it's a blue sky day to get our
stuff
out there we're already moving moving as
much as we can that we can get our hands
on
messaging here there have been obviously
a fluid situation
but um you're the guy at the top can
you help tell people what is actually
going on
do you know what's going on with what's
going on with the power right now
sure sure so
so here's what's going on with the power
there are multiple sources of power
that go into the power grid that attacks
texas
and i'll just take them off one by one
one source of power is the south texas
nuclear project that power source was
down until
has progressed and should be fully
operational
as of tonight i'm going to go through
these
another source of power that is
generated that goes into the power grid
is power generated either by
coal or by natural gas some of those
coal and natural gas
power generating facilities either froze
up or had mechanical failure
and were incapable of adding power to
the power grid
okay
sure
exact zip codes and locations of where
the powers
don't have what i can tell you is this
and that is
there are certain areas uh that fall
within the zones
of the uh investor run
uh power distributors uh and those are
let we one second here
information about which location
and which geographic location uh the
additional power
is coming onto or or is not coming on to
you so er ercot is a an
independent private entity uh
that uh candidly
i have both investigated prosecuted
before when i was the attorney general
of texas
uh and we're now investigating again i'm
not suggesting in any way that
there's been any criminal activity or
anything like that but
it is something that needs to be looked
at with regard to it's
it is kind of opaque the way that it
runs it's not transparent
and one thing that everybody needs out
of ercot
is greater transparency especially the
residents across the state of texas
never seen before
all the way down does this change
anything and where is this life of
priority
just let's play obsession for you well
we want to this session make sure that
we
address these challenges just like what
we did in the aftermath of hurricane
harvey it
was important to be able to respond to
the challenges posed by hurricane harvey
this is a different type of climate
event this is a
once in every 120 year cold front event
that they have to respond to i will say
this and that is
the last time the state dealt with
something like this was actually in
2011.
there was a severe cold spell in the
state of texas at that time
that led to changes both with regard to
ercot but also with regard to the power
system in the state of texas and so
this session we want to undertake the
same type of review that was done
in the session in 2011 maybe reevaluate
some of this some of the decisions that
were made in 2011
but we want to we want to make sure that
we are capable
of ensuring that the state will be able
to withstand
uh cold spells like what happened this
just talk about the need time conserve
energy and maybe what you've done with
state agencies
to turn lines up on buildings you know
around the capital
et cetera first i will tell you that
allstate agencies have been actively
involved
uh in conservation of energy turning off
power whenever and wherever possible
as well as we've seen residents and
importantly downtowns let me mention
this
real quick as many people reported
there were downtown buildings that had
lights on
while other people had no power at all
in the cities around those downtown
areas i saw last night it looked like
in downtown houston they had shut off
their lights
in the downtown area and those buildings
i i don't know what happened in the
other large downtowns but
turning off lights that are not needed
right now would be a way
there would be more power available on
the grid that we would be able
to get to residential areas as a result
we urge everyone but especially the
large users of power
to do everything possible to keep your
lights off if they are not needed
you